Wir haben ja hier schon öfter darüber berichtet der wettlauf um den mars hat begonnen neben moment mal den mond
Hat jetzt auch der wettlauf um den mars bekommen ja jetzt haben jedenfalls
Die chinesen konkrete pläne für eine grüne kolonie auf dem mars vorgestellt konkret geht es um einen komplett
Vertikalen wald wie die kolonie auf dem roten planeten aussehen soll und wie
Realistisch diese idee wirklich ist und wie ist die lage auf dem mars jetzt den klicks. Im science fiction herzlich willkommen
Nicht wenige gehen davon aus dass in spätestens
100 jahren bäume auf dem mars wachsen die es dann auch möglich für uns menschen machen dort zu leben wir berichten hier ja immer
Mal wieder über eine mögliche besiedlung des mars allen masc mit spacex ist ganz vorne mit dabei jetzt hat auch die
chinesische
weltraumorganisation pläne zu einer mars kolonie vorgestellt in zusammenarbeit mit dem italienischen stararchitekten
stefano boeri soll eine grüne mars kolonie entstehen mit sogenannten vertikalen
Wäldern und dafür ist der künstler bekannt schon 2014 hat der architekt das projekt bosco vertikale abgeschlossen ein
vertikaler wald quasi anders ausgedrückt zwei begrünte hochhäuser in mailand und das ist wirklich beeindruckend das eine haus ist beispielsweise
27 stockwerke hoch und misst knapp 120 meter an seinen seiten wachsen tausende pflanzen hecken sträucher und auch ganze bäume
und das ist wohl auch in china auf
Interesse gestoßen es folgten mehrere aufträge für bo ehre unter anderem arbeitet
er jetzt daran einen kompletten chinesischen stadtteil grün zumachen laut seinen plänen sollen in der forest city also waldstadt in der chinesischen stadt
schwaz lang
100.000 menschen leben können dabei geht es lediglich
Um eine fläche von 2 125 quadratkilometer die unzähligen pflanzen dort sollen seinen angaben zufolge die
lebensqualität der menschen dort stark verbessern denn bäume und andere pflanzen würden nicht nur die luft reinigen sondern würden auch für eine natürliche
Dämmert doch seine künstlerischen projekte wieder nicht nur auf der erde umsetzen sondern bald auch
Im weltraum konkret hat stefano boeri
An einem projekt mitgearbeitet in dem ideen entwickelt werden sollten wie wir in 100 jahren leben könnten
der name des konzepts new shanghai
falls dann der meeresspiegel die erde mehr oder minder
Unbewohnbar machen sollte hat wo er also vorgeschlagen eine art öko stadt auf dem mars zu bauen den riesigen
versiegelten kuppeln sollen türme stehen die mit pflanzen bedeckt sind diese runden hülsen artigen gefäße
Sollen zunächst von der erde auf dem mars gebracht werden und dort dann die grüne kolonie
Bildnachweis idee würden auch wir menschen in diesen kuppeln leben was für einen ganze
abgeschlossene ökosysteme die wie eine art
Samen auf dem roten planeten gepflanzt werden könnten dieses projekt ist
künstlerisch angehaucht seine installation kann man mit augmented reality technologie
schon heute hautnah erleben doch an diesem projekt ist nicht alles nur kunst tatsächlich sind auch die tongji
universität und die chinesen raumfahrtbehörde beteiligt doch wie genau soll das ganze tatsächlich
funktionieren die bedingungen auf dem mars sind ja nicht gerade der
Lebensfreundlich auch wenn der mars der planet in unserem sonnensystem ist der der erde am ähnlichsten ist nicht nur die
durchschnittliche temperatur von minus 56 grad celsius
Die würde es uns menschen dort sehr schwer machen zudem gibt es was ich wenig sauerstoff die atmosphäre besteht hauptsächlich aus
Kohlendioxid und ist etwa 100 mal dünner als hier auf der erde
Spezielle raumanzüge müssten leben auf dem mars selbst zu dem von der kosmischen strahlung
schützen das sind also die bedingungen die auf dem roten planeten vor herrschen und die
zukünftigen kolonien müssten diesen trotzen wie das genau funktionieren soll dazu hat sich die chinesische
weltraumorganisation noch nicht konkret geäußert aber sie haben ja noch 100 jahre zeit um das ganze technisch umzusetzen
Realistisch betrachtet ist die ganze idee derzeit allerdings nicht mehr als eine kühne vision doch fest steht china hat große pläne und
Alles sieht bislang danach, aus als würden die chinesen dem westen in sachen
Weltraum schon bald den rang ablaufen schauen wir mal wenn er kein video zur entwicklung der raumfahrt und auch zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
Dann wird mir hier ein abo aufs auge und vergesslich den
Genau auf die glocke nur dann verpasst sie auch wirklich kein video hier geht es weiter mit dem video zum thema
Helium-3 abbau auf dem mond durch wen wohl
china sehr sehr spannendes thema und ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran